senate democrats just passed a 740  billion dollar bill called the inflation  reduction act the bill does a lot of  things it sets aside 369 billion dollars  in the green energy industry it extends  obamacare subsidies for an extra year it  raises all sorts of taxes it even  increases taxes on gas and oil imports  pretty much the only thing that the  inflation reduction act does not do is  reduce inflation as the penn wharton  budget model showed last week and as 88  percent of democrats already know  according to a recent yougov poll and as  even bernie sanders admits when he  refers to the behemoth legislation as  the quote so-called inflation reduction  act these are bernie sanders words quote  i say so-called because according to the  cbo and other economic organizations  that have studied this bill it will in  fact have a minimal impact on inflation  it's not my best but you get the point